have we spoken about Con on
Earth I've not seen we should because
it's the best show ever oh my God it's
it might be my favorite show this year
um I love Kunk and there's a lot of Kunk
history as well
on was on Netflix but there's a lot of
other stuff just discovered KK on
Britain um didn't know it existed it's
very very good like she is phenomenal
there was this there's just so much of
it so funny and I know it's in part her
performance and I don't doubt she has
creative input but also the writing team
um there's a big team of people that
make that show work the way it does and
there's this one bit that just killed me
yesterday in conon Britain that was like
Santa you know you have to make sure
that you're you're good that's the way
that you get toys from Santa um but
that's actually not true because the
good kids and the bad kids get toys
equally it's actually based on if you're
poor Santa judges morality based on the
income of your
parents she's killed me so good and like
her delivery is just oh my God it's I
love it so much definitely it's a pH
it's a frasia situation because she was
like one charact she was a she was one
of the characters on a show called
screen wipe which was a Charlie Brooker
kind of yearly Roundup show and she was
one of the talking heads on that Diane
Morgan playing that character and
obviously just now has spun off into for
you for everyone who has no idea what me
and Lana are talking about like the kind
of yeah exactly I know it's it's um
she's like a basically a fake
documentarian who has not done the
homework and just shows up and it's all
shot very beautifully like a you know
classic BBC documentary but with a host
who is genuinely completely unaware of
what's going on it's kind of a modern
day Alan Partridge it's kind of in that
kind of M the more I watch Alan
Partridge the more that I've realized
how he just influenced all UK comedy
like 100% oh my God and it's so good uh
but yeah I she like
interviews people who work at
universities and have actual credentials
and ask them the dumbest possible
questions and I feel like it would only
work in the UK that they're all aware
that they're being that it's a joke but
they don't try to one up it like they
they're all very dead pan and serious
and just answer the stupid questions in
a way that's like well uh are they real
people or they are real people which is
crazy because their performances are
like perfect I'm sure they do a bunch of
takes but I've only seen one of them try
not to laugh one time it's just I think
you'd like this Austin I think this so
this is bra but in other words it's not
like the um Sasha Baron Cohen like the
uh Borat interviews and things where
it's like someone doesn't realize
they're being no they would set up yeah
it's much it's actually kind of nicer
than that not me did on the joke yeah
yeah exactly that's one I when I was in
college I loved that stuff and then the
older I got the more I was like some of
these are actually quite cruel uh cuz
some of these people really are in good
faith trying to Age and and while he is
a brilliant sort of performer and
comedian like on a crazy level Sasha bar
and Cohen yeah there's definitely I
definitely found myself kind of falling
out of love with that format pretty
aggressively in in recent years I think
yeah I liked it when I was a lot younger
and then more recently end up just
feeling bad for people all the time that
yeah like they don't know particularly
when it's
people you know where they the whole
premise was a lie where they're like
they're very busy and you can feel their
sense of urgency so then it's just like
immediately you know kind of hackles
raised and I was
like it's it's kind of I mean how is
this not fraud I mean when you're like
misrepresenting yourself again I I don't
I don't I don't mean to make too big a
thing of it because I I some of it is so
hilarious that I have to kind of like
and also kind of like win yeah plus he's
just so he's just so good um he very
it's like a show it's much more yeah
it's it's about catching people out
rather than right right yeah though aded
this is on Netflix no I'm saying this
sorry yeah I'm saying punk is is not
that but oh yeah yeah but I was going to
say that I think that like it's not even
a mean spirited uh um prank show Borat
in that it's like any topic we just get
very invested in God um it because I do
think it's American satire and it's it's
trying it's trying to catch Americans
out in that way like it's not like it's
like YouTube pranks now where people
just go into a Target and throw at
someone right like it's like a little
more intentional than that but yeah
certainly some mean stuff in there um
anyway hey everyone welcome to playw
watch list and I didn't intro the last
episode so let me remember to do this
one um does that mean we're still in
that episode yeah technically it hasn't
ended it never ended yeah I'm video game
right that's Mike ble That's Mike ble
he's video game director that's awesome
mystery he's a video game composer
that's your knee that is also my knee
with my I you know face from my yeah I
still have the scar from the motorbike
accident that feels like 50 years ago I
know and I still have trouble with that
knee um in any case today I offered a
topic which might be the first time
we've ever done that um that's not true
yeah it might have happened first time
let's debate that for 20 minutes let's
just debate that for 20 minutes I feel
like that was our I feel like the first
like 30 of these we would kind of
brainstorm and then we eventually were
just like let's just turn on the
microphon and see what happens for an
hour I think the first 20 of these were
just the opening level of Jedi surv Jedi
uh fall in order though a commenter made
me laugh quite hard the other day
because they were like oh Troy's too
busy because he's still on the
train that's why he couldn't join us
last week he never got off the train
that's that's accurate yeah um the topic
that I often the way we are all still on
the train sorry and I never got off the
bus which is a charge Gambino reference
that I think about often um the topic
that I offered was game Direction I'm
sure we've spoken about it before but uh
this year especially I saw people
confused about how you know Allan Wake 2
won game Direction at the game awards
and balers gate 31 game of the year
which I vehemently agree with like I
think that is the right call that feels
right for sure um but I think that
there's a lot of like what is game
Direction people don't understand what
game direction is and how you can award
it separately from Game of the Year um
and I think there have been some games
this year that have perfect game
Direction but aren't necessarily 10 out
of 10 games I would offer RoboCop as one
of those that game has like perfect game
Direction but a bunch of that's not
you know 10 out of 10 in other areas um
but the tone is super consistent the way
that the mechanics feed into the
gameplay is super consistent all of the
writing is very very funny uh even if
there's like Ultra violence like it's
just so like tonally perfect and every
system that is in that game feeds into
every other system in such a
complimentary way uh which I would
consider to be excellent game Direction
feel the same way about the Yakuza
series like they all have such good game
direction that that that game can pull
off having a stupid sex mini game where
you like have to flirt with people on a
phone sex line and pick the right
answers but then also has like a plot
about a woman who was so traumatized it
turned her blind and they both
cohesively exist in the same absurd
karaoke simulator franchise is good game
Direction um so Allan Wake 2 Mike have
you have you played a bunch of it now
did you get around to I've not played
any of it yet I I'm I I've set myself
the thing I have to replay one before
I'm going to let myself uh you need to
do that I'm gonna though I'm gonna and
I'm I'm I will get to I'll get to both
have you played
control yes cuz I would recommend
control even before replaying Allan Wake
one really
that dives into that as well just it's
just fun yeah I think the only one I've
not played was I played a bit of break I
don't think I didn't get get super far
in that one also related James mcaffrey
uh who voices Max Payne and Alex Casey
passed away this week after a long fight
with cancer super super super
sad 65 I think yeah maybe I'm not not
sure um super sad but
also um was talking to some Ramy team
about it and just very glad that he was
able to see how much people loved the
game um at the very least like this year
like people loved it so much and his
performance so much uh but just glad
that he was able to see that um and very
thankful for his work super iconic Max
Payne's like one of my favorite video
game characters ever so Legend yeah um
Mike isn't it fascinating how the game
industry is still so comparatively young
that things like that happening are are
so striking still that we lost pain is a
huge deal
yeah yeah like there's there's you know
cuz the film industry like if you're a
film and TV buff one of your favorite
people invariably Will Go On Any Given
year if not several because it's just
been around for longer than any of us
have at we had voices in video games for
50 particularly acting but really in any
capacity you know like any like major
director or it's it's still pretty
uncommon you know you like at the Oscars
they can easily do a several minutes
Montage where they rapidly go through
and there's still a bunch of names that
invariably upset people for having been
left out yeah and I think you know I've
seen them do this a time or two like at
GDC like at at you know or or at you
know some other kind of high-profile
event but not for the first 10 plus
years of my career and even then it's
it's fairly rare you know it's and and
when you think about like a really
high-profile name like his what was the
first video game voice we had I don't
like first voice say that's probably the
I think it has to have been 20125 years
25 probably um first video because I
mean I was playing well to be clear I'm
also talking about any any any um any uh
like
like you know like a game director or a
high level like animator or you know
like for example lost a few of them
we've lost like some luminaries of like
yeah and the it's true no I I'm not I
don't mean to suggest that's not the
case U uh but U like for example
probably the highest
profile um game composer death that I
can think of was the the one who did uh
the first
couple um David cage like Beyond Good
and Evil um he
died
um uh cuz what was the one that was
after that
um um that they did that David cage did
um heavy rain before heavy rain is like
his big claim I guess it was I think it
was beyond good and evil was the one
Heavy Rain was right before Beyond Good
and Evil right Fahrenheit
far yeah because he I remember it he was
not quite able to finish that uh Norman
um I'm suddenly blinking out Corb um and
then like uh Dan licked who scored
honored one and two but he was those
were I think his only two games really
he mostly was known for the guy that
scored the TV show Dexter and a bunch of
other television
interesting but yeah it's it's it's it's
fairly rare and just it's a fascinating
yeah it's a fascinating thing that
that'll become far more normal as the
years go by like we have can you imagine
what's going to happen to the industry
when we lose like
mamoto yeah exactly it'll really really
really rock people because it sort of
hasn't happened to someone of that scale
um apparently the first I'm getting like
conflicting reports but the
first fully voice acted game was mad dog
McCree which released in 1990 arcade
shooter um that was that was that that
was
FMV was it interesting okay cuz
something else also mentions it
something using intell voice a game
called Dragon Lair which is also an
arcade game but I don't know what
intella voice means oh shout out to
everyone else over the age of 35 that
just died at the lack of awareness for a
lot there of what dragon
was so Dragon Lair Dragon's Lair was an
arcade laser dis game where you played
like a night doing qtes basically
interesting back back in the day you you
if I show it's it was Don blue animating
so if I showed you like you probably do
recognize it
um but yeah know that probably maybe
that's weird then that voice basically
happened around the time of like FM
because both of those were FMV games cuz
um would been like vo there would have
been like there was definitely voicing
games in the sense of like like
recordings of like Sega this game looks
awesome but in terms of full voice which
one
Dragon yeah you're about to go down the
rabbit hole cuz that is like that is key
that's arguably one of the first like
narrative driven games interesting and
then wait they made a movie
afterwards they made a dragon's La movie
they released I think they released like
it was anime ated game was like a
pre-rendered animated game with QT
basically you were watching an FMV of an
animation so I think they then released
the animation as a movie as well I think
used it in both places wow cool it kind
of coincides with Bluth leaving Disney
and
doing oh was he
fival eventually was wasn't he there was
something else before americ T Land
Before Time what was the one he did that
secret Nim I think that was his big kind
of breakout one after he left Disney and
then Dragon's Lair was kind of him
dipping his toe into the gamees world um
interesting Good Times yeah well it's
way further back pretty satisfactorily
explains what game direction is I feel
pretty good about what's game Direction
what do you
do take credit much um I think I think
take credit that's good thank you I the
speed you can tell I make that joke a
lot um I think I think the I think
actually kind of nailed it with kind of
what when you were
describing the the the some of the some
of the nouns and verbs and adjectives
you were using when you're
describing why it felt right that say
Alan Wake 2 one of directors right it's
about tone it's about consistency it's
and it's about kind of a it's about
plugging everything into each other
someone described it to me like that the
other day like it's
basically how do you plug things in it's
it's and and I've always used like the
like the idea of curation as a shorthand
that I don't do the paintings but I've
set up the gallery really well and I've
made sure that you have an experience as
you move through that it feels
consistent it feels logical that that
flows together you've got all these
amazing artists doing everything in a
game um but you need someone or in you
know some projects a couple of some ones
who basically make sure everyone's
pulling in the same direction yeah so
it's it's a creative leadership kind of
role there are other ways of doing it
um I use
um do no I love that go ahead sorry go
ahead so so so it just works because
nerds have generally seen Star Trek yeah
but like Star Trek basically is I would
say probably the best like pop culture
depiction of what leaders do like in a
sense that you watch a captain week to
week kind of making decisions and you've
got kind of the Kirk who's the kind of
I've got like two or three trusted
people I basically Go My Own Way you've
got Bard who's like let's have a meeting
and and gets everyone in the room
together you've got like Cisco who's got
a vision and doesn't really care what
anyone else says and is going to
go for it because they he knows it's
important you've got Jane way who's like
putting out fire like you've got all of
these kind of throughout that franchise
this is a really this works as an algy
because I know Kirks and I know Picard I
know Jays I know cisos and it's I think
there's I think it's the the core
problem you're always trying to solve is
bringing up bringing together everyone's
work making sure that it feels like a
consistent single piece and and being in
charge of creatively owning and leading
that aspect of it and then different
directors have different backgrounds or
different layers of Interest so those
parts of the game they may take more of
a Hands-On approach so with me for
example I come from graphic design and
game design so like I'm very much in the
room with the design stuff I'm very
annoying with the UI stuff and graphic
design in general and I write stuff as
well so it's like but then there's other
directors who come from a coding
background so they're focused on like
the Innovative stuff on the text side or
you've got like so I would that would be
an example of Matt Nava is an artist
through and through Visual artist he was
the art director you see it time and
again like different and you can kind of
point to like youo Sam lake is obviously
a big and Kima as well big film nerds so
you can see a lot of that influence kind
of come through and that's and then and
then that all gets channeled through the
kind of the the OU reading of stuff
where people kind of uh you know
attribute certain qualities in the work
to an
individual sometimes that's true
sometimes it is that individual driving
it sometimes it's just that that person
has a particular collaborator or
collaborators that they like to work
with so like there is a look to hideio
Kima characters but is that kajima or is
that because he keeps working with
shinkawa you know that's the there those
those kind of but he just keeps deciding
to work with Shar there obviously there
is some kind of ownership there so yeah
anyway it's about curation and about
bringing together bunch of people's
working okay he Vision so I agree with
you Allan Wake feels like it's that
Fantastics like and to be fair most of
the remedy games do they feel like an a
Very consistently pulled together vision
and I think the reason bers G all
sprawling and massive and impressive but
I see the hundreds of people there I
think what that draw Boulders Gate 3
again it was my game that game's
fantastic was my game of the year um
incredible it if you compare to Alan we
2 in terms of um game Direction it does
what it sets out to do absolutely
perfectly but Allan we 2 is so distinct
in terms of tone and style it is like
nothing else in the choices they've made
and the only way those choices can
actually make a cohesive enjoyable
experience like the very bold very
creative there's a goddamn musical
sequence inside of it just it's just
like shocking how creative it is is with
very distinct game Direction whereas
it's not like balers Gate 3 doesn't have
good game Direction it just I don't
think it can stand out as much uh with a
game that's not making like very absurd
choices that's why I also use yakaza as
a really good example or like the
RoboCop example of I think that game has
such good game direction is because it's
so tonally specific it's very very 80s
it's very violent but also super
humorous um and yeah literally all of
the systems including even like your
level up mechanics will just feed into
this same really cohesive thing in a
super impressive way and it's hard to
Wrangle that many people like game
direction is certainly not an easy thing
to like get everything on the same page
I think yeah I think it almost requires
very specific choices to stand out yeah
yeah so you can kind of see the director
right that's sort of what what we're
saying it's like if you can see the
director in it it's probably got good
game direction if it has a the
personality I think the things you say
tonal consistency which was something
you read mentioned with RoboCop like
that's and that's what's interesting and
why that's interesting I think I can't
remember if I said this on the show or
or after one of our recordings but
that's that's what's fascinating to me
about working on license games is
licenses kind of help you as a director
because there's a lot of rules already
set up so you kind of can be consistent
almost not quite by default it requires
a bit of work but you there's a there's
a North staff you'd be especially if
everyone's seen RoboCop they know what
it is it's it's slightly easier so
there's so there's so and that's not to
diminish anything the RoboCop because it
achieves a lot but there is a there is a
support there and that's definitely
something like working on Tron stuff is
a lot I'm I'm making arguments to what I
think is good but I'm also making
arguments towards what the franchise is
and that that does that the franchise
acts as a co- director a little bit and
it's an interesting kind of aspect of
that yeah um you mentioned that it's
like being a creative director but some
games have a game director and a
creative director what does that mean
what do they do so I don't fully that
one Austin might be better placed to
answer because the and you of course you
I have the perfect answer but I throw it
to somebody else I think I think it's
the from my understanding I'll give the
outside perspective I'll give the
ignorant outside perspective which is
game director is focused on the
experience the experience the
experiential elements of the game and
creative director is largely focused on
the Aesthetics and you know Aesthetics
including audio and sound and The Vibes
that's my understanding tell me where
I'm wrong on that Austin do you
have any um it's not common yeah I've
I've had experiences
uh with both most of the projects I've
worked on had a single creative director
um but there
are um there are games where sometimes
it's divided based on kind of along the
lines where there's like game game game
director is seemingly shorthand for game
play which is very much about how we
unify mechanics and the actual player
experience from a almost a technical
level but it's obviously not just
technical in the sense of of uh you know
bugs or engineering or something like
that it's about the it's this whole
cloth look but without having to also
spend just as much time thinking about
the narrative and the Aesthetics and the
the the more kind of uh surface facing
part of it obviously the success of a
game especially if you're talking about
a game at a huge scale um is on the
those people's ability to be in sync
with each other because the player
doesn't really ideally experience them
separately from one another even if even
if you'll see that or if reviews will be
like well the gameplay was great but the
story was crap or whatever like that's
that it is fairly easy I guess to
disentangle them but like I remember on
Assassin's Creed for example I'm pretty
sure there was essentially there were
there were more than just those two
because if memory serves it was
essentially like a gameplay director a
narrative
director um o obvious other art direct
like director on the same level cuz like
usually you'd have like a narrative
director and an art director that would
be below game director I don't think so
although although because of the nature
of the way they were set up the all
things audio were delegated to the audio
director who was my main person that I
dealt with and so I I I didn't interact
much with the folks above her there was
also even more senior level like brand
director who would oversee multiple
Ubisoft Studios making multiple AC games
and their job was to make sure that
everything seemed to gel from one game
to the next so it's like there's all
these different sort of checks and
balances of folks going does this cohere
and given the scale of it it's a miracle
it works at all because just the scale
of what's being attempted there is so
insane um but that's also never part of
the narrative right with directors like
the the coherence thing is whenever I
say that to someone who doesn't work in
games that's like a big it's both a
revelation but it's also like really
they kind of act like well that just
sounds like you're in middle management
it's like yeah kind of like that like
ultimately that you're the glue that
kind of pulls everything together I
think we have this idea of directors
being you know from the imagination of
the Visionary director of blah blah blah
blah blah like and actually no cohesion
ultimately like we are gluing things
together and and you're basically judged
as a director on your ability to put a
bunch of good people in a room and then
make their work coordinate and work
together you know
um sorry so uh Alan White 2 is
co-directed I I thought it was just Kyle
Rowley and that Sam was creative
director but it did from what I can see
it was Sam Lake and Kyle Ry who both
directed Alan way too um because I know
that what was your answer to the the
question so very similar to what Austin
said um which is one is more systems and
one is more tone uh but they still have
to work together and have a partnership
and and santon studio is in a really
unique position where Cory um I think
was credited as creative director on God
of War Ragnarok but he's actually
franchise director is uh one of his
various titles um which I've never heard
of existing in any other Studio though
I'm sure it does which means that
definitely Ubisoft
has so like obviously when when we're
working on the God of War TV show but
then also working on God of War Ragnarok
but then also working on God of War um
Ragnarok Valhalla the DLC that just came
out uh and that has um without any
spoilers like references to the earlier
God of War games that also Cory also
worked on of course it's sort of his job
to make sure that the whole franchise
doesn't fall apart like a franchise
overseer which I can't even imagine how
stressful that is for Cory uh it's a lot
because it's so the the franchise is now
so big too um that you know they're
books and comic books and there's so
much God of War content that yeah his
his job is making sure that the
franchise
always makes sense um and touches on the
right things at the right time and he's
also probably more aware of like a
future pipeline than anyone else who
works there really is of like what else
is coming before they tell the rest of
the stuff or whatever um so it's
franchise director also I think in his
case is very closely tied to creative
director anyway because he is overseeing
the entire tone of God of War uh which
again I'm yeah I'm sure exists elsewhere
I just never heard of it before and I
can't even imagine how awful that job is
but yeah essentially um one half is
that's not to say that game director
because our game director for God of War
Ragnarok you know he still had a huge
amount of input on the story and I'm
it's not like he didn't touch those
parts like it was still very much his
baby
um I yeah I guess creative director in
my head is just more tonal
consistency in but it's it's got to be
so flexible as well like they all are
and also if like
if I can do one of my favorite rants
which is the games industry needs to
stop stealing words from the film
industry without knowing what they meant
in the film industry beyond the
director's commentary one of the biggest
issues we have not one of the biggest
sorry one of the pathetically
unimportant issues we have we've got
some issues some real issues that
actually impact people's lives but the
one that annoys me so a lot of what
you're describing with like a franchise
director that's just a producer in the
film industry and it's a really
interesting split that we we kind of use
producer to mean person makes sure
people get things done yeah yeah and
that and that's kind of that is that is
one kind of producer in film that's like
a line yeah I wouldn't have thought that
that was a producer in the film industry
I would have thought in terms of in
terms of ownership of a franchise in
terms of the stuff you're describing in
terms of like making sure everything at
a franchise level or Brand level ties
together yeah that's generally producers
generally that would be
um so like Kevin feig is is
essentially perfect example of this or
like you know when I I don't think I'm
talking stuff I shouldn't talk about but
like a lot of the people I work with at
Disney are producers I'm not there is no
interesting I'm going to just stop
myself before I say something I
shouldn't say public but like there's
but I was going to say producers tend to
be the people who own this
stuff who does the money in a lot of
cases in film ex both the most important
person on the team and the least
important person on the team in most
film I'm making film in uh probably
March and I asked a friend who's a
producer to help with producing it uh by
which I mean um effectively I don't know
how to make this tell me what I need to
do kind of producer as well that's a
kind of producer as well for sure but
it's I think that's the thing for me is
the is we because we've elevated in the
industry and I know in film it's it's
definitely also there's five different
meanings to every word as well like this
is unique to us
but I think the games industry jumped on
the word director very quickly because
Spielberg's cool and everyone's heard of
more people have heard of Spielberg than
have heard of brookheimer like by I feel
like director makes sense we may be
misused
producer uh oh no director makes perfect
sense my point is we call a lot of jobs
director we call there's a lot of things
we call director that you would actually
that maybe there would be better terms
for but we also have a unique problem of
um not not a problem it's not a good way
to put it but
uniquely to film you know you work on a
film and you're contracted to work on
that one film and not a lot of these
people work full-time figy being an
exception obviously he's a full-time
employ but like a lot of films is just a
group of people one time and they're not
we kind of have to have a structured
hierarchy so that people still have room
to be promoted like there has to be like
a pipeline of jobs that keep going
higher you know you end up being your
department director your art director
cinematics director whatever because you
you you kind of to keep people in a team
you have to give them a a place to go
well we also have brilliant things in
the games industry like the principal I
uh where you have someone like where you
can take people at a certain point in
their career in the games industry and
go do you want to be in management or do
you want to keep doing the thing you're
really good at and that there's a hold
there's there's kind of two available
Parts which is exactly what you're
talking about that kind of it it pulls
into that as well um what's interesting
actually is and and this is based
entirely on publicly available
information um there's uh Marvel one of
the reasons Marvel was able at you know
for for a decade to get out as much
product as they did was that they were
run more like a games company in the
sense that they had a lot more full-time
members of Staff they had kind of a core
art team who would basically be doing
the development the R&D the development
the pre-production stuff on the whole
franchise at once with a standing team
so like you know the guy who did the
concept art for Iron Man was still there
to 10 years later in a full-time job
that's how you get that again the only
way they can pull off what they did I
think like game is such an incredible
feat that nobody else would probably
ever pull off again right like that's
really the only way you can do that is
if it's all the same
people for as long as possible we've
been talking about film for about 10
minutes without asking Austin who works
frequently actually works in
film Austin there all this this
fuzziness uh of terms is is everywhere
you know for example in
film the director
is um in most cases very much the buck
stops with them they are the final
decision maker on most things but it
also depends on the film because there
are producers who control the money that
often will have an enormous influence um
even if you know if you hate it it often
will be laid at the director's feet even
if it was due to producer meddling and
then in start contrast to that you've
got television where directors
are um
um far less influential yeah showrunner
is director right the showrunner is the
person who is yeah exactly the who kind
of owns the creative um uh vision from
this as high level view as as possible
um but there's also variety other than
that because there's a classic tradition
of whoever directs the pilot is kind of
influent like for example famously uh
Frank darabond directs the pilot of The
Walking Dead and kind of set the vision
and then walked away and well I know
studos do that intentionally sometimes
where they'll like hire a bigname
director to shoot the pilot so that
every other director who comes in has
that to follow already yeah it lets some
it lets they're they're banking on some
more urish type to kind of like help
create a template for yeah for the
machine to then be able to duplicate for
you know year after year after year um
and um so that's one model and I like
personally how in
games there's like a CL there's like a
class of people that are the director
level folk like when I was working on
Lego fortnite you know there would be
I'd get I'd get uh the audio director
would come back and say well we just had
a director's meeting meaning all the
various director you know like audio
director gameplay director art director
there you know the overall creative
director they would all have like a kind
of Council of the ring you know um and
and go through what needs to get done
and then disseminate that information to
their respective department so like I
like Eric our creative director on Lego
fortnite he he actually Congratulations
by the way I didn't even know you
wereing on that it's so huge it's been
crushing it yeah I've been I've been so
I've been uh I've been absolutely
delighted that that uh it's been as well
received as it has um epic really pulled
off Quite a feat on just like dropping a
whole bunch of new stuff kind of all at
once and pretty much all of it seems to
have gone really well but um but like so
our our our director Eric uh um he took
a particular interest in the music and
so he we had a lot of meetings with him
and we would do playthroughs of the game
uh where he would talk through kind of
the vision behind certain things and and
was um involved even though technically
my boss was are the audio director and
like everything one you know funnels
through him whereas like on Assassin's
Creed Syndicate um I I I met the the
most senior level like creative director
and the narrative director and those
folks I met them kind of at the
beginning I visited the studio and shook
hands with everybody and then we kind of
high-fived at the end when I visited the
studio again to like go through and and
do bug fixing and stuff with them and
like a few traded emails here and there
and then like at E3 but otherwise I was
daily talking to the audio director
where they delegated to her to such a
degree that that um you know like
she know she would sort of encourage me
to make polarizing choices and would be
like that's for me to deal with not for
you if if anybody pushes back or
whatever she is that
unusual Syndicate was unusual in that
way in so far as I was encouraged to be
so against type for the rest of the
brand like if you listen to Assassin's
Creed Syndicate music compared to
basically all other AC games yeah it's
really quite different and part of that
was my pitch but then part of it
was uh Lydia the audio director who who
had said at the very beginning like we
want you because we want something very
different um and then I was like are you
sure like I kind of assumed that that
was a bit of a platitude and so I
started to deliver different assuming I
was either going to be redirected or
fired and somehow neither of those
things happened but I will say just to
make a point about kind of the director
role about conceptually what they do no
matter which kind we're talking about
that notion of
cohesion just to give a little bit of an
insight into how that looks from my
angle and and what I love about great
directors is there's this common talking
point in games and in film and
everywhere when dealing with composers
where the person who's who's on the
other side of the table is me is like I
don't know how to speak music I don't
know how to ask for what I'm looking for
I don't know how to if I hear something
I don't like I don't really quite know
how to tell you what I want to like it's
a
common everything you hear this every
single director all the way up to huge
you know like DreamWorks and Pixar they
all say the same thing and um so one of
the so every composer has kind of their
ways of getting around that a classic
one that many of us use is we'll say
talk to us like we're the actors you
know you don't necessarily like
directors are taught don't line read for
the actors or don't don't try to kind of
overly micromanage but try to explain to
them the goal of the scene and then let
them figure that out if you if you
basically use the exact same language of
the composer then you'll likely get
results that will work because it's our
job to sort of translate what that means
but one of the reason a lot of ways you
are
also you're like the music director sort
of not audio director but like your job
is
so singularly creative and no one else
really would often know how to even do
it you're sort of a music director true
I guess other departments don't know
about writing Danny Bole calls it the
little director approach which is what
he does so Danny Bo film director
obviously he um he refers to every he he
calls them his little directors and it's
not
patronizing with a British accent it's
fine directors um My Little directors
you're over there I don't know why I'm
doing a British accent you're good at
that the uh no I'm sure um but like that
idea of like that that's the great
that's how you respect people who work
for you is you give them all authority
and autonomy the the music thing is
funny because I definitely have said
that to you Austin when we work together
I know that's something I've said to you
for sure is because I I I think I've
said it to everyone um but I I think
that's the the the kind of the the
director Whispering that kind of upwards
management is something that I think
every why hiring so important really
great people are very good at doing that
hire people you trust and then but also
people who work for a director knowing
how to communicate with the director
that's a skill in itself as well I
someone and I think weirdly composers I
think generally among the best because
they jump around as much as they do
Austin has worked for more directors in
his career than we ever will than we
ever will yeah
um I need to go BL my nose be right back
I really have to blow my nose composers
are amazing of that I think part of it
also is is
that um in both games but especially
film there's a certain sense of the
director on some level or another could
do most of the jobs that they hire
others but who are better at them than
at those jobs now gaming this breaks
down a little bit because there are G
you know like like Ken LaVine is not a
programmer for example so I don't at
least I don't think he is he comes from
you know theater and writing background
so like there so it's not a perfect
thing whereas in film it's not that
uncommon that you have someone who if
push comes to shove if if you lock them
in a room with a camera they can they
can shoot they can write they can edit
they can even act and maybe not well but
they understand it yeah exactly it it
and but music is almost always the
outlier you know like you see a lot of
the the you know the I mean even even
looking at at um um like Thomas Was
Alone or like Andy shots making Monaco
you know like still needed a compos it's
one of those where there's like there's
a huge slice of the game that is 100%
delegated and the rest is like mostly
shouldered by the Mike or the Andy of
that situation the the the um the little
tip I was going to bring up uh as you
know something that I've picked up on
the last number of years that I always
encourage young composers but I think
this applies to literally anybody who's
kind of trying to pick to learn that
director Whisperer skill is I always
say just basically try in the spirit of
that initial point that was made a
little bit ago about cohesion look at
how the other elements of that have been
directed and use that as your main
Direction Where because while there are
cases where occasionally the director is
like Okay so we've made this very high
octane very kinetic you know very rapid
fire kind of very colorful flashy video
game and in contrast deliberately we
want the music to be very slow and
meditative as that's the that's going to
be the interesting thing that's a
relatively uncommon thing normally I'm
looking at it and going okay I see so
the mechanics are starting to line up as
you know moving with this General sense
of Rhythm the art Direction has this
kind of General sensibility to it what
can that tell me about the music so that
they don't even have to sit there and go
well I I'm kind of picturing something
that's very metal-ish or I'm picturing
something very like old school symphonic
orchestra or whatever the in film this
is in a way a lot easier because in post
the the film very closely resembles its
actual self so I'm always looking at the
two main things how did they shoot it
and how did they direct the actors
because the same page of of script can
be shot you know big wide angles super
open or like tight claustrophobic same
lines but it's so emotionally different
viewed through those different ways of
of shooting it and lighting it whatnot
that it will inform the music before the
directors even open their mouth so I'm
always going to analyze those choices
that they've made up but you're doing
you're doing a little bit of the
director job there which is great like
and something I remember from working
with you um that you are probably the
most curious about what else is being
done on the project of any composer I've
worked with um and that's a that's a
great thing to be clear that's a cool
thing I think that's
partly in service of working out what
the music needs to be but also it's just
because it's cool I love yeah that's
Austin is as a person that's who that's
true try try and not let Austin get
interest not be curious give it a go
yeah but like I think that's something
the pH what else do they put gas
[Laughter]
in yeah no I I I I always encourage that
I always I always say you're very good
at that it's interesting like do you in
anything that you studied did you have
to learn about film making like for you
to pay attention to you know the way
something is shot and what kind of lens
evokes what's what emotion are you doing
that from a like totally subjective like
opinionative standpoint or do you have
to study
that uh it's mostly just
that
uh because most of my friends were
always the filmmakers like it's one of
these self-fulfilling things if you like
hanging out mostly with game developers
and writers and actors and producers and
editors and filmmakers and game
developers
basically it's going to be probably a
little e easier to build a career as a
composer in that field because your
Social Circle is filled with the people
that either will hire you or know people
that might want to hire you where
whereas and we'll be having chats down
the pub about the things you need to
learn and and about to do that job so
then it's just it's just to me it was
always just a completely unplanned
organic byproduct of who my friends are
where it's like hey so what did you do
today oh man well we had this crazy bug
with our animation uh system but it was
the coolest thing when we realized what
it was doing and and so then you
suddenly find yourself in an hourlong
conversation about just how they make
their craft because not because you're
I'm trying to learn it for purposes of
my professional interest it's because
this is my friend and what's going on in
their life and I care about them as a
person and therefore I am interested in
what's going on in their life you know
what I mean so it's like these things
have second order effects that are
professionally beneficial but that
wasn't the main motivation I mean like
for example there's a film director
named damin matala who I've done a few
features with who I met when I was a
student and he was a student at at the
American Film Institute doing his
Masters in directing and this is someone
who you know we would go to movie
theaters once a week and for for 10
years you know and and constantly watch
things and sit there at the you know the
ark light after it was over and he would
say oh my god did you notice that shot
where then and we would just un unpack
it especially from his angle as a
director and why he was so in awe or
what he didn't like about better that
kind of thing and he just learned so
much by proxy but this is just because
he was just a friend you know it it it
so that that's but but I I do
nonetheless encourage it for
professional reasons of of folks
especially just getting started uh
because it's helpful it's a good it's a
good way to put everybody's
communication on the same page so you're
not talking past each
other and I would think that this
applies to
all disciplines like from your angle
Alana writing the more you actually
understand how games are made the more
you can actually do that job I would
just assume that's intuitive right I
mean yeah
um I can't give my actual answer to that
question um but it is important to me
obviously to work just in the generalist
sense I'm not I'm not obviously asking
for there's something I would love to
say but I'm not I can't I want to hear
that
answer my answer is in the vaguest way
possible no I'm not even GNA do it um
obviously for my job I have to work
really closely with other departments uh
and they inform the things that I do and
I inform the things they do so yeah you
like and that's like one of my favorite
parts of the job is like getting to talk
to level design about whatever thing
they did and um it's it's super fun and
super rewarding and and I think surely
the the more you know the people that
you work with which I guess we keep
coming back to even more so than
understanding the discipline like I
don't know how to design a level uh but
I I know how the people that I work with
do that um and that I think makes
everything in terms of pipelines just a
lot a lot easier and smoother and easier
to follow intellectual curiosity is like
the most important trait I look for in
interviews I look want to be friends
with it's the best thing like being
excitedly interested in how everyone
else does their jobs and respectful but
the excitedly interested is is
ultimately all this is I I I think I've
probably made this joke before on the
show like I'm just I'm just the first
person who gets to see everything yeah
and and have an opinion and that's
ultimately my job um and that's amazing
um so yeah and that's the that's the
angle to take yeah I think you'd have a
lot of trouble being a director if you
didn't have that yourself too right like
you have to oh I've met I've met
intellectually incurious directors 100%
like yeah it's more your ot to I'm going
to tell everyone exactly what to do and
they must do exactly what I say I guess
some of
do work like it's
not if you have a strong yeah like if
you're an and very clever it can
work but you don't tend to be very
popular yeah I I I I would be
hardpressed to
name any project that I've ever worked
on with a director like that that
actually then turned out well or at
least was not very obviously hampered in
some like oh this would have been so
easy to fix if If Only They
I think it's easier on small teams and
that's that's why I get my back up a
little bit when I've I've I've seen
discourse happen where it's been kind of
oh bad working environments only happen
happen in Triple A that will go round
Indie circles every now against like no
no no there's definitely like Indie
teams that are that where people have
been treated very badly by these kind of
directors um so yeah so it's a it's a I
think it's easier on smaller teams for
the exact reason you said earlier Austin
of like uh in film and I think in Indie
it's very true as well that like if the
director is someone who could
theoretically do most of the jobs that
are happening within the team then that
can lead to very inflated ego where you
know people are guess an example of
um a director name and shame though
obviously well a director on an indie
team that that stands out to me um that
I think had that
reputation would be um Steve gaina who I
that was the name I thought you'd go you
were about who like to be clear I was
very good friends with and you know did
not know about anything that happened at
full bright but that story did come out
um and I guess the story was along the
lines of like Steve uh they made G home
very famously um
was I don't want to like painted
incorrectly but it I feel like it was
painted as an almost sort of abusive
director um but the games that
Fullbright
made wouldn't show that I wouldn't have
thought they obviously had production
struggles in the end as a result of that
uh
environment um I don't remember I think
it was open roads was the last game that
they were working on and it it became
very difficult to make um but I don't
and I don't know the time in production
I think the team are still building that
but yeah there's the I think that's true
or at least it was a little while I'm
almost certain I saw a trailer for that
uh recently like yeah I think that's
still happening just without and again I
think that that probably is a thing that
happened as a result of um even calling
that poor direction is maybe not even
the correct way to put it but but you
wouldn't have seen it in the previous
two games that full rght made which I
think is very interesting like gone home
is so beloved and and um so critically
acclaimed uh maybe it wasn't there at
that time but that's the one that stands
out to me probably more than anything of
something that I remember happening and
uh yeah I always uh I always
um it's always tough to evaluate these
things from the outside
um
I uh I remember hearing a story once
I'll I'll keep all the names out of it
but this is from the film industry
anyway but there was a um pretty big
director who was meeting with composers
for a film and meets with one guy and he
says I think it'd be really cool if it
was like Very Metal like big Orchestra
but like electric guitars and the
composer
said yeah I I caution against that it's
really easy for it to quickly just sound
like w WWE and uh I don't think that's
probably what you're looking for and
director goes
okay well anyway I'll be in touch then
calls said composers agent and goes your
client is such an arrogant piece of
and like lost their mind over the and
it's one of those where I heard this
story from the
composer who obviously did not get hired
for this film um who they were
bewildered that they apparently came off
as extremely Brash and arrogant when
they were offering what they thought was
a helpful suggestion and and I remember
hearing that and I
go there's probably five versions of
this story and none of them are quite
definitive on who was kind of like
hackles raised the most or who was felt
their ego most challenged or and I'm not
trying to make this as any kind of
direct uh comparison to the Steve G I
don't know what happened I remember
vaguely reading about it I don't know
any that all came out I think I I yeah I
don't I don't know I've met him but I
don't know anybody else in that Circle
or anything so I I I'm not trying to
make any kind of comparison or anything
but I'm just saying um it was
fascinating to hear how insanely
one-sided it came across uh for for such
a you know kind of um for such a
statement where I was like I think some
people in cases like that particularly
have huge egos they just hear whatever
no matter what you say they will hear it
a certain way yeah uh and that those
kinds of
folks um can be Geniuses but they just
tend to not be great directors uh if
they it's a filter the best advice I got
was really early in my first like lead
role I was a lead designer um working
for some other people and uh the best
advice I ever got it was basically like
you get to decide as in a lead role you
get to decide basically are you going to
be the to filter on the quality of the
work by basically having to make every
decision yourself because then you're
ultimately and you can't make anything
better than you you are going to be the
limiting factor you're going to be like
you know like hitting the top of your
graphics card like there is a a finite
amount of power there if you decide to
be the if you go down the curator route
if you become someone who tries to
empower the people around you you can
make stuff that's better than you could
do on your own but that requires uh that
requires giving up the ownership that
requires giving giving up that
egotistical kind of mentality and I
definitely kind of had to learn that
lesson like fortunately I had time to
learn that before Thomas Was Alone which
meant that when when Thomas Was Alone
did well and I could hire people I had
that kind of attitude from that from
that from basically being told off for
being a bit of an egotist early on um
because it it can be very dangerous to
be kind of someone who can only make
things that you if you're just
instructing other people to do things
that you would do yourself then you're
ultimately limiting yourself to to that
capacity I mean it's like look look at
the uh Stark AB comparison of Spielberg
who I mean paraphrasing or quoting as
essentially saying my goal is to be the
dumbest one in the room you know is to
is to surround myself with all these
people that uh wh hold
on holding on
H don't tell me you want
recording it right as I said hold on it
stopped and I've restarted again I don't
really know what made it stop that was
weird um Team have just power yeah
exactly um so so Spielberg reportedly um
you know very much will defer to to
folks but then you have like
Tarantino who who is like exerts such
extreme control over so much that that
and you can feel it in in the aesthetic
of his films they're extremely
consistent where you're like only he
could make these and there was even a a
quote recently do scores he like because
he wants to pick the music crazy yeah
and there was there was an interview
where he was like I don't want to trust
some composer like some person who comes
along and just puts whatever in the
movie and you just Stu with like hateful
where it I didn't realize I bought the
vinyl of it the other day the hateful
eight soundtrack is just I thought it
was original music but it's all music
from old westons right no no no hateful
eight is the one and only exception
which and it ended up winning an Oscar
for score which is the most brilliant
irony of it all but oh cool okay that
was Eno Marone who was like his Idol who
he worshiped and that one I thought that
was also using Marone tracks from
earlier films it did do that as well
though there are bits there are so so
morone wrote a score to the John
Carpenter movie the thing that got
thrown out and was not used and and
that's what I'm confused with Tarantino
used of thing a score for the thing what
of that's hard even picture it's it's
totally speak of vs who like control
over their sound contracts John confer
is an excellent excellent example of and
and that's also a study of uh producer
meddling I'm pretty sure the thing the
reason why morone was hired was like
okay you're making a slightly bigger
budget movie Mr Carpenter you need to
hire a real composer instead of just
whatever keyboard stuff you do in your
bedroom but they ended up not using
really any of it and so um the unused
music from the thing is a huge chunk of
what's in the H flate although to be
fair the vast majority of it including
like if you watch the big you know like
Road Show version and stuff it opens
with this 10-minute Overture and all
that that is the actual score it was
written for hateful eight um I just
remember my favorite scene in the film
was where they drink the poison and they
start like vomiting the blood everywhere
and they're tripping in their own and I
remember thinking the music was such an
inspired choice for that scene and of
course that was music from the thing and
I was like damn it uh you can't judge
tooly cuz me and you have done the thing
we're describing here where you I used
an unused piece of music from you from
one project
for radio I did so the North Star Rising
was the the the co uh radio sci-fi radio
comedy thing we did and uh and yeah the
the the music for that is this is this
is you put this out there it was your
Star Trek my unused Star
Trek awesome I I was I was listening to
that and I was like this is really good
this should be in something and then we
that's really cool really well yeah it
is it is those things do happen it is it
is I heard one
recently I can't say what it is but I
had a composer reach out to me and say
hey by the way I'm using this
thing for something and I I I should
give you thanks because this thing that
I'm doing is actually because I was able
to rescue a piece from a pitch on a
project I didn't get that you got and so
now I'm using this music on this other
thing and I'm actually really happy with
it and so so in a way thank you uh which
was a funny
like years later um all right I have to
run for hanging out everybody there
won't be an episode next week cuz I am
going to the
woods I'm very excited about it um we'll
see you in January stall yep uh thanks
for for a wonderful
2023 to both of you and to everybody who
listens to the show we appreciate you
see you next year bye
cheers